in Cambodia the Mekong River is still
wild and untamed it's where the last May
Kong population of Irrawaddy dolphins
lives there are said to be just 80 of
them this stretch of the river is now a
conservation area de Blois used to be a
fisherman now he takes tourists to see
the dolphins come come on low I don't
earn any less from ecotourism than I did
as a fisherman you might get out my hope
more tourists come that would be good
for our community we create lots of new
jobs made you get you on the pumpkin
painting River guards monitored the
protected areas some fishermen use
electric stoners and explosives dolphins
often get caught in gill nets fine mesh
net anchored in place on the riverbed
but now there's a new threat Cambodia's
neighbor layoffs wants to harness the
waters of the mekong for a hydropower
project a mega dam is to be built right
on the border sun wrath who heads a
large communal the border is concerned
i'll give nicole knows i am now our
dolphins and fish stocks will disappear
the water quality will deteriorate in
the dry season will have too little
water and run they open the floodgates
during the rainy season it will endanger
humans and animals near the river banks
not wholly experts fear the dam will
block the migration of the rivers fish
that would deprive thousands of
fishermen of their livelihood and the
impact is even more far-reaching fish is
a staple food and the most important
source of protein in Cambodia jetsam ask
from the world wide fund for nature
hopes layoffs will relent eve the
downtown going to be beer and a negative
impact including the quality of the
water including the
a density of the ridge of history and so
on I could not be put not addressed so
in rican of we could not recover back
you know the number of fees and so all
very new to me because a habitat of
doping has been thousand thousand years
ago the mekong would be poorer without
its dolphins and their welfare mirrors
the survival of the entire ecosystem